I saw this word, "Gireogi-abba",...
...a goose father.
What does it mean?
I'm sure it has a symbolic meaning just like the word, "Deun Jang Nyeo".
That word appeared in an article, which talked about...
...an increasing number of family members...
...children and mothers going abroad,...
...primarily to study English.
So I'm guessing,...
..."Gireogi-abba" means a man going through a midlife crisis...
...while his family lives far away from him?
Am I on the right track?
You are! To be more specific,...
..."Gireogi-abba" indicates a father, typically around forty years old,...
...who endures a life of solitude after sending his children and wife to study overseas.
Let's see, it's like the word "a grass widower",...
...meaning a man whose wife is temporarily absent.
When a man reaches middle age and goes through a midlife crisis,...
...there exists a period of frustration and feelings of pointlessness.
They feel down in the dumps.
Imagine how he has...
...to endure this when none of his family members are around him for support.
Wow, Korean parents are very devoted to their children.
I do understand a little bit, but...
...when a man reaches the age of 40 something,...
...I guess it's time for him to prepare for his own life...
...you know, spend time and money on himself.
But what I see in this highly competitive country...
...educationally, parents are just ready to sacrifice for their children.